with all the fanfare that befits egypt's
ancient kings and queens the highly
anticipated
and meticulously planned pharaoh's
golden parade
was the biggest cultural event cairo has
seen in recent years
traveling in individual vehicles
bedecked in ancient egyptian style
the mummified royals 22 of them in all
were moved from cairo's egyptian museum
in tahrir square they moved through the
capital streets to a new location
a state at the art facility called the
national museum of ancient civilization
[Music]
where they were greeted by a concert
from the cairo philharmonic
featuring famous singers and then
received by the egyptian president
the pharaohs are the staff of legend and
include amenhotep the first
ramses ii ramsay's the third and queen
nefertari
you've got two worlds really coming
together you've got the curators who
normally move these things
without the world watching and prepare
objects to travel around the world but
then you've got a spectacle that needs
to be put on
so the logistics behind it were very
complex and you can imagine they've been
working for a very long time and i think
they've really pulled it off it's got
their spectacle
but we also felt that everything was
done safely
the security operation was a mammoth
undertaking streets were closed and
cairo
brought to a standstill the event which
lasted around two hours
was attended by various dignitaries
including the director general of unesco
the un's world heritage organization
once the mummies arrived at their new
resting place they are to be put into
restoration in a lab for 15 days
and readied for display but there are a
minority who muttered darkly
about an ancient curse legend has it
that cursed will be the ones that move
the mummies
they say the suez canal blockage
disturbing global markets
two trains colliding with each other a
garment factory blaze and a residential
building collapse
all came after the announcement of the
pharaoh's golden parade
but the ancient curse hasn't stopped the
pharaohs once again
appearing on the streets of egypt
imran khan al jazeera